Друзі, всім привіт! Цю романтичну алею японських сакур
висадили у Бонні у 1984 році.
Подивіться, як вона відтоді розрослася.
Ці дерева, як і тисячі інших у Бонні, потребують догляду і захисту.
Тож, пропоную у цій серії розібратися, як німці піклуються про зелені насадження.
Сакури приваблюють у квітні до району Бонна Альтштадт -
"старе місто" - тисячі туристів.
По акуратно сформованим кронам дерев видно, що за ними старанно доглядають.
Окрім естетичної краси японська вишня
ще й очищує повітря у загазованому центрі міста.
Однак Бонн може пишатися не лише своїми сакурами -
тут чудово почуваються і велетні-каштани,
і платани,
і секвої…
Загалом на вулицях Бонна висаджено щонайменше 30 тисяч дерев.
Усі вони захищені законом.
Керує доглядом за ними "головний садівник" Бонна - Дітер Фукс.
Наш відділ догляду за деревами має різні райони,
закріплені за старшими садівниками - так званими "ґертнермайстрами".
Наприклад, цей парк Райнауе
є одним з таких районів зі своїм страшим садівником,
у підпорядкуванні якого ще приблизно 15 робітників.
Ще у нас є бригади догляду за деревами, які виїжджають
в разі потреби по цілому місту.
У підпорядкуванні пана Фукса - 285 людей.
Бонн поділений на 11 районів,
закріплених за старшими садівниками.
Одна з комунальних бригад із догляду за деревами
сьогодні працює у центральному парку Бонна - Райнауе.
З німецькою точністю і прискіпливістю всі дерева парку
занесені до електронного кадастру і пронумеровані.
Керівник бригади всі результати сьогоднішніх робіт
щодо кожного дерева фіксує у своєму планшеті.
Тут ми видаляємо всю засохлу деревину
і трохи вкорочуємо дерево, тому що
йому  трохи бракує життєвої сили. Ми бачимо, що запропонував контролер:
вкоротити засохлу деревину приблизно на 5 сантиметрів,
зменшити частково крону.
Я маю вписати сюди причину, чому я це зробив -
у даному випадку для безпеки руху.
Тепер просто зберегаємо ці зміни - і дивіться,
дерево, яке тільки що було позначене помаранчевим кружечком
і яке ми вже обробили, тепер стало зеленим.
Я прошу показати всю історію дерева.
Ґідо жартує, що дерева не підпадають під закон про особисті дані,
і показує історію верби. Я щиро вражений:
у кадастрі є своєрідний паспорт на кожне дерево.
Нашій вербі 53 роки. Висота - 14 метрів,
є розмір її крони, стовбура,
а також дати і результати усіх попередніх пеервірок дерева.
Контролер перевіряє, чи безпечне дерево для руху на дорозі.
І коли дерево у такому поганому стані,
що контролер вважає, що дерево слід зрубати,
тоді на нього мають подивитися ще двоє людей.
Це додатковий контроль, який ми здійснюємо.
Здивувало мене й те, що стан дерева мають перевірити
аж троє людей, перш ніж вирішити, рубати його чи ні.
Знак "Обережно: обрізка дерев" і стрічка,
натягнута по периметру падіння гілок,
застергіає перехожих і велосипедистів не перетинати зону робіт бригади.
За рухом на доріжках стежить працівник з рацією.
Вважливо, щоб ми між собою могли комунікувати.
Бо коли ти весь вкритий кроною дерева, тоді ніхто нікого не бачить.
І якщо хтось із перехожих заблукав у зону робіт,
я маю встигнути попередити, щоб припинили пиляти.
Цікаво, що амбушюри навушників виготовляють індивідульно,
враховуючи форму вушної раковини людини.
Так само роблять професійні музиканти,
що виступають на гучних концертах. Навушник, що сидить у вусі,
береже його від зовнішніх децебелів від бензопили.
Після інструктажу з техніки безпеки - залажу у кошик підйомника,
щоб відчути, як працюється у кроні дерев.
Ну що ж друзі, а зараз підйом на висоту 22 метри.
З цієї висоти парк Райнауе я ще не бачив.
Подивіться, яка краса!
Один з робітників бригади Клаус сам може і пиляти,
і керувати підйомником.
Гілка дуже довга і не достатньо стабільна під час вітру.
Через це я її вкоротшую.
Так буде ясніша картина.
Для догляду використовую електричну пилу,
її легше завести, і вона менше важить, ніж бензинова,
та й більш сприятлива для довкілля, бо не має викидів.
Бензопили ми використовуємо для щільної деревини,
коли треба спиляти ціле дерево.
Виявилося, що пиляти гілки у кошику підйомника - справа не з легких.
Вітер хитає гілку, до того ж розхитується сам кошик.
Без шолома із забралом-сіткою, щільних рукавиць і спецвзуття
зі сталевим носком пиляти заборонено.
Спускаюсь на землю і питаю головного садівника Бонна:
а що станеться, якщо хтось надумає спиляти дерево самовільною
Коли хтось у приватному порядку зрубає дерево
з нашого реєстру, тоді вони отримають штраф,
гадаю, він може сягати 50 тисяч євро.
По закінченні робіт бригада подрібнює всі гілки -
тирса з них піде на компост - і прибирають за собою всі сліди.
А фахівцю я поставив ще одне ваше запитання з коментарів:
як у ФРН борються з омелою?
Ми, власне, нічого не робимо.
Бо проблема з омелою полягає в тому,
що вона вже глибоко всередині тіла дерева.
Тож, ми не можемо повністю видалити паразита.
Птахи їдять білі ягоди омели, перелітають далі,
і таким чином омела розповсюджується.
А як же діяти, якщо треба сприляти дерево у себе на приватному подвір'ї?
У ФРН діють такі правила: якщо дерево на рівні один метр від землі
має охоплення стовбуру понад вісімдесят сантиметрів,
необхідно отримувати окремий дозвіл у мерії в управлінні зелених насаджень.
Їду на інший берег Рейна - у містечко Бад Гоннеф,
де на приватних подвір'ях багато дерев, яким по сто, а то й більше років.
Я завітав до пані Соньї Шваґер.
Її родинний будинок побудований у 1936 році
ледь не зазнав серйозних пошкоджень, коли ураган Фредеріке зламав навпіл
20-метровий кедр. На щастя, ніхто не постаждав -
дерево впало на порожню проїжджу частину.
Тоді я зателефонувала рятувальникам.
Вони приїхали, порубали дерево
і перекинули його частини з дороги мені назад у двір.
Однак тут залишився ще стояти велика частина дерева.
І була велика загроза, що воно завалиться.
Тож, приїхали люди з мерії, щоб все це задокументувати
і видати мені спеціальний дозвіл на вирубку.
Я чекала на дозвіл 14 днів.
Ось так виглядає письмовий дозвіл на вирубку дерева від мера містечка Бад-Гоннефа.
Треба його зберігати при собІ й після того, як дерево зрубали.
На випадок якщо раптом пильні сусіди, яким подобався вид з вікна на дерево,
наскаржаться відповідним службам.
Тепер дров для каміна з поваленого кедра вистачить ще на багато років.
Однак на цьому історії з поваленням дерев
на подвір'ї пані Шваґер не закінчилися.
А тут стояла дуже велика ялина.
Я боялася, що оскільки тут залишилося лише одне дерево такої висоти,
наступний великий шторм може це дерево теж зламати,
а мене, можливо, в цей час не буде вдома,
щоб проконтролювати, коли це станеться.
Тому я запитала місто, чи можу я це дерево теж зрубати.
Просто через побоювання, що воно впаде на будинок сусідів.
Після виїзду експертів і контролерів на місце та обстеження дерева
було ухвалене друге позитивне рішення для вибурку -
на підставі того, що під час вітру, якщо стояти біля дерева,
відчувалося, як коріння піднімає землю.
До дозволу мерія додала також припис про зобо'язання господині
висадити замість повалених нові дерева
і перелік, які саме породи дерев це можуть бути.
І звичайно ж, доклали рахунок за виконані послуги - 115 євро.
Друзі, а зараз хочу показати вам те, що мене особисто дуже вразило.
Подивіться на розмір цієї секвої
на подвір'ї будинку пані Шваґер.
Для розуміння масштабів порівняйте розмір дерева
і будинків, які стоять біля нього.
Секвоя настільки затіняє садочок, що у спекотний день
тут можна спокійно проводити родинні пікніки.
Незважаючи на те, що коріння могутнього дерева дещо псують
вид ідеального газону, господиня у захваті від невибагливого гіганта.
Ми взагалі ніяк не піклуємося про це дерево.
Єдине, прибираємо голки, які опадають навколо.
Цікава деталь: одного разу, коли пані Шваґер
поралася на своїй ділянці, викопала з-під землі дві кам'яні лавки -
дуже схожі на витвори періоду Римської імперії.
Також знаходила дерев'яні старовинні інструменти для ремесел.
А біля своєї ділянки пані Шваґер
викопала гранітний солдатський надгробний хрест і каску,
які зберігає на знак пошани до померлих.
Якщо кущі й дерева на приватній ділянці будуть неохайними
і заважатимуть руху на проїжджій частині
або розростуться на ділянку сусіда -
можуть виписати штраф до півтори тисячі євро.
А ось так відбувається догляд за деревами навколо медіакомпанії DW.
Підприємства зобов'язані самі дбати про те,
щоб зелені насадження на їхніх та прилеглих територіях були доглянуті.
Вони можуть замовити послуги у приватних фірм
або сплачувати внески міським комунальникам.
Роботу біля Deutsche Welle виконує двоє людей.
Андреас Маукіш сам і гілки пиляє, і керує підйомником,
який нагадує гібрид механічного павука з місяцеходом.
Його колега прибирає гілки і водить вантажівку,
яка перевозить підйомник.
Ось тут аварійна кнопка, тут вгору і вниз.
Кошик перевернути, кошик обернути.
Вниз вгору, лівроруч, праворуч - все це керується чотирма важелями.
А чи любите Ви вашу роботу?
Так, безумовно. Я отримую задоволення. Завжди десь на іншому місці,
внизу, вгорі. У дощ, вітер, у будь-яку погоду.
Це чудово! Я нічим іншим і не хотів би займатися.
Друзі, у коментарях ви запитували, чи білять німці дерева.
Відповідь - так, але не всі. І ось він приклад.
Однак дерева фарбують не з нагоди першого травня
і не в комплекті з бордюрами. Вкривають спеціальним захисним шаром
лише нововисаджені дерева, щоб вони
добре прижилися на новому місці.
До речі, подивіться на ці нововисаджені дерева.
Їх привезли сюди на пересадку не з садового центру, а з Баумшулє
– дослівно "школи дерев". Чи цікаво вам дізнатися,
що це за школа? Та що ще б ви хотіли знати
про Німеччину - пишіть у коментарях,
і я обов'язково розповім про це у наступних серіях.
Побачимося!